gives me
c5o all right fair enough when you're
right you're
right Eric gives me long diagonal to
tango why are you giving him the long
bag all right but look there's something
that I have too but I'm not going to say
it out loud want continues to give me
the long diagonal to
jenko oh no the diagonal that all my
pieces are on no might attack my
king I might that's a good
idea think that in this game well I'm
attacking yours are worth more than
KS I mean the map the way I play yeah
actually the way I play you couldn't be
more right all
right I don't understand you just sit
there and look
[Laughter]
pretty I like the way you
talk yeah you know what it
is
Eric begging for a draw CH I this is
such a good end game for
white rather hang
aade that might have been the most that
the best
you
he got me
bro how
God my back hurts from taking all your
pieces
something you would say from carrying
your own to
you
my sack the
queen uh don't help
him just kidding this is what it's like
when God has a
gun